Well,
I think that we will probably need some
new institutional arrangements before
this is over.
Um,
one that I've called for,
uh,
in,
in a number of places including my book
is it's a world environment
organization.
I've worked in the UN,
I can tell you that,
uh,
if you look across the landscape of the
UN agencies,
uh,
it's probably true that the weakest ones
are the ones that are there for the
environment.
Uh,
and that's not good.
We need a world environment organization
that has the kind of authority and clout
that the World Trade Organization has.
And that's an easy case to make.
Um,
but,
um,
I think the World Bank could have a big
role.
It could create special arrangements and
special facilities to help deal with
these issues.
And the best thing about the UN program,
uh,
are in this area are the,
you know,
basically the,
is not appreciated that widely,
but all of the international treaties
that worked to protect the environment,
uh,
most of which the US has never ratified
a,
but all of those treaties,
uh,
are sponsored by the United Nations.
The these negotiations that happened
every year to strengthen the climate
treaty.
Now looking to a post Kyoto Protocol,
uh,
looking out to 20,
50 to reduce greenhouse gases.
That's,
uh,
that,
that process,
uh,
is,
is under the Framework Convention on
Climate Change,
which is a UN sponsored exercise.
And the secretary at sit service those
conventions and it's sponsored.
The negotiations are UN entities.
Uh,
and problem is that that system doesn't
work nearly well enough.
Uh,
it's,
it's a one country,
one vote,
a system,
and a country's can whittle down these
agreements to the point that they're
toothless.
And the real problem now is not the poor
is not weakened forcement of the
treaties.
Uh,
it's not weak compliance with the
treaties.
It's just,
it's a treaty.
So toothless,
they don't require much in the first
place.
And so we need to develop some new
machinery for international
negotiations.